There are three kinds of
donuts, sugary ring donuts,
sugary jelly-filled donuts, and
then there are the ones that
are really bad for your health.
These ones.
Well, I can see why people
pay money to watch this.
But take any friction
fighting hijinks to the roads
and it's a serious hazard
for motorists and for trees.
They were okay, but
extremely lucky.
So you should
never attempt this.
But off the road, and in
the hands of an expert,
donuts are a masterclass in
static and kinetic friction.
Our driver hits the gas
hard and turns sharply.
The excessive torque
at the rear wheels
overcome static friction between
the tires and the ground,
so they become subject
to kinetic friction,
which offers less resistance.
The reduced grip allows
centrifugal force
to slide the wheels
in a circular path,
like the ring of a donut.
So not just risky,
but scientifically
tricky to pull off, although
not everyone seems to think so.
I mean this guy thinks
he's got the science down,
but in fact he hasn't lost
traction at his back tires
at all.
He's just using rollers, see,
which does reduce the risk
of kinetic friction,
burning up the tires,
but doesn't make
it less dangerous.
CAMERA MAN: Woah!
Watch out, man!
BEN AARON: It's a
bit late for that.
Ah, the parking lot donut,
using kinetic friction
and centrifugal force to drift
into a space, like a glove.
Having successfully
turned static friction
to kinetic at the
rear wheels, he then
momentarily let up the
power on those wheels
and went back to static.
So, he stopped circling,
and went straight.
There are better
ways to park a car.